le nouveau rapport sur nos océans qui se
vident publié par l'université de la
colombie britannique affirme que 30 %
des poissons qui sont pêchés en mer ne
sont pas signalés parmi les chercheurs
de cette étude
daniel pauly professeur à l'institut des
océans de la pêche à université de la
british columbia
vous avez besoin de savoir combien de
poissons sont disponibles pour
l'alimentation des gens et de danse
surtout 20 pays du tiers monde
terriblement sous-estimé c'est
sous-estimer parce que les pêcheries
traditionnel donc les pêcheries à petite
échelle les petits métiers ne sont pas
vraiment tenu en compte ne sont pas
apportées par les pays
et c'est justement ces pêcheries là qui
alimentent les réseaux les marchés des
denrées monde et donc c'est parfaitement
aberrant qu'une pêcheries locales ne
soient pas tenus en compte alors que
perry étrangers a tenu en compte parce
qu'elles rapportent des devises
étrangères
en fait c'est pas la gestion qui est
important ce que là c'est la
compréhension du rôle de la pêche et du
rôle de ces pêcheries artisanales et
subissent ans dans l'alimentation
par exemple les stratégies de
d'alimentation les la revue de la
situation alimentaire des pays du
tiers-monde
elle doit tenir compte des pêcheries
mais comment ce qu'elle va le faire s'il
n'a pas donné sur ce que les gens manger
ce que non ce qui ne mange pas par
exemple si un pays commence à exporter
sa pêche à exporter les produits de la
pêche au lieu de les consommer
localement c'est important localement
mais on ne saura jamais si on ne
considère pas la consommation locale
le fonds mondial pour la nature a rendu
public lui même son propre rapport sur
l'état des océans dans lequel il
soutient que la surpêche croissant de
plusieurs espèces tant de poissons que
d'animaux marins vertébrés
comme les requins et les tortues ont
fait chuter de moitié leur nombre en
l'espace de seulement quelques décennies
énormément de gens que nous ont été
contraires qui en dépendent juste pour
le canada s'est fendu ce mail personnes
qui vivent de la pêche au canada et un
pib de trèbes et 3 milliards de dollars
alors imaginez ce que ça fait à
l'échelle internationale sophie paradis
et porte parole francophone du fonds
mondial pour la nature
il ya pas si longtemps dans les années
60 plus un citoyen moyen mange et 10 kg
de poissons donc de produits glaneurs
annuellement on a doublé tout ça dans
les dernières années donc déjà là on
pousse une pression supplémentaire sur
vos jeux c'est un de nos pays si vous
savez on aime beaucoup de fouchy donc il
ya une demande des pays occidentaux qui
est plus croissante par rapport à la
demande d'emploi sont donc en en
produits de la mer écoutez le pour trois
milliards de personnes sur la planète
le poisson constitue la principale
source de protéines en france
s'approvisionnent directement de
poissons d'auxi et non plus de gens une
surpêche beaucoup de gaspillage ou si
c'est faux ce verre quand il arrive sur
tout ce qui arrive avec les mauvaises
pratiques de pêche c'est que on a ce
qu'on appelle du bail catch ouvre de la
pêche qui ramassent tout qu'on ne passe
pas nécessairement par exemple du temps
on peut ramasser des requins on peut
ramasser des ready tortue est ce qui
fait que sa ville où je suis né je fais
un combi et biodiversité que l'on
attaque en ayant des mauvaises pratiques
de pêche les grandes questions
maintenant
doit-on arrêter toute la pêche en haute
mer peut-on arrêter cette pêche en haute
mer
une étude menée par des biologistes
marins d'université 5000 faisons
toujours donc sur la côte ouest
canadienne pose est carrément la
question les conséquences de l'arrêt de
la pêche en haute mer
re même un impact économique minime mais
y compris dix en fin de compte il avait
le côté et professeur en écologie et en
restauration marine à l'université 128e
on arrêter la pêche
en haute mer ou quand on arrête la pêche
à peu près n'importe où dans le fait en
ce qui se passe et que la biomasse de
poisson le nombre de poissons la taille
des poissons augmente et après un
certain temps on a un effet de ce qu'on
appelle un super love
alors cette cette biomasse accumulé
commence à se disperser vers les zones
qui sont ouvertes aux pêcheries alors le
résultat de deux ça c'est que les
pêcheries peuvent bénéficier les prix
augmentent et les revenus augmentent à
l'extérieur de saison strictement
protégée alors on sait on peut être
qu'ils le même principe à la haute mer
si on fermer complètement la haute mer
sont transformés la haute mer en zones
strictement protégée on s'attendrait à
ce qui inspire au goût de poisson qui
augmenterait les les prises dans les
zones économiques exclusives
alors la place par une des choses que
cela qui nous a vraiment surpris dans
cette étude c'est qu'on a examiné le
nombre d'espèces y la valeur économique
des espèces qui étaient pj seulement en
terre et en fin de compte il ya
seulement à peu près 1 % des espèces qui
connait capture et en haute mer et si
j'ai fait cela vraiment une valeur
économique très très minime alors si on
fermait les eaux la haute mer il ya
vraiment très peu destin est en fait dû
senneurs j'espère qu'ils qu'on ne
pourrait plus touché du tout le reste
des spurs distribuer entre la haute mer
et les zones économiques exclusives
ce sont des espèces qui vont de d'une
heure à l'autre une option pour
préserver ce qui reste des stocks de
poisson et éviter que nos océans ne se
vident davantage serait de contourner le
poisson comme source d'alimentation des
algues cultivées en mer par exemple du
temps en symbiose avec l'aquaculture
pourrait se vendre à notre alimentation
de tous les jours sous forme par exemple
de terrines de soupe de tartare au goût
pas aussi bizarre qu'on la présente
peut-être on pourrait aussi incorporer
ces algues à
bière l'azoté le phosphore est très
important pour les algues et puis donc
en venant ici au nouveau-brunswick dans
les années 80 donc c'était le début de
l'aquaculture du saumon et donc avec
l'aquaculture du saumon on a beaucoup
d'azoté de phosphore donc je me suis dit
tiens
est-ce qu'on peut pas rapprocher les
deux il y en a il ya un composant qui
entre l'arc du phosphore et de l'azoté
en a un autre qui en a besoin
au canada thierry chopin et
l'ambassadeur des alpes peut-on dire
ce professeur de biologie marine de
l'université du nouveau brunswick au
campus de saint jean donc à deux points
finalement de l'océan atlantique et le
directeur scientifique du réseau
aquaculture intégrée du canada pour moi
cette combine et de deux histoires qui
sont typiquement du nouveau brunswick on
à l'aquaculture intégrée au nouveau
brunswick et où notre équipe est très
avancé au niveau mondial et puis on a eu
des gens qui font des micro brasseries
quand on peut combiner deux bonnes
histoires de nouveaux points 6 j'espère
aussi qu'au niveau touristique etc
ça pourra avoir des bonnes rose retombée
donc il ya la bière aussi on essaie de
travailler sur les actes dans les dents
les chocolats la même chose aussi c'est
l'aspect sucrées et salées
on travaille avec une compagnie de
shediac a donc on a fait des premiers
essais et donc on espère cet hiver aux
médecins pour travailler des
formulations faire pousser les accès
l'aspect scientifique c'est aussi
contrôler que qu'elle soit bonne pour la
consommation avec une agence canadienne
d'inspection des aliments
et puis donc on a par exemple analysé
nozal pendant huit ans et elles ont
toujours passé l'inspection donc elles
sont bonnes pour l'alimentation humaine
et donc ça c'est l'aspect scientifique
mais pour moi c'est toujours l'aspect
développer des démarches et et si on
peut combiner deux ou trois histoires du
nouveau brunswick pour moi c'est
l'intérêt
un reportage de radio canada
international